you
[Music]
this morning on the Dish award-winning
and best-selling author and TV host Elie
Krieger born and raised in New York she
always loved good food and went on to
study at learning degrees in nutrition
from Columbia and Cornell not bad she
also pursued a career as a Wilhemina
fashion model and learning to find
balance and wellness helped inspire her
life's mission helping people enjoy
great food in a healthy way
well this coming week she'll release her
seventh cookbook this one for busy home
chefs hole in one complete healthy meals
in a single pot sheet pan or skillet le
Krieger good morning and welcome to the
dish good morning it's so good I want
you guys really such a treat to be here
Oh enough about us about this beautiful
table yeah so basically we're all eating
kind of family-style now but each one of
these dishes is actually a complete and
nutritionally complete meal that is made
either in a sheet pan pot or skillet so
that is one thing that I love about it
and this chicken for example I just
think it looks fabulous done and it's
grilled chicken it's basic it's all made
on one sheet pan so it's like easy
weekday or weekend cooking I want
weekend's to be easy to you yeah right
yeah
and also again nutritionally you know
just helpful and complete meals then
that's soup over there that mmm so
that's a butternut squash soup and I
make it a whole meal by putting a whole
can of chickpeas pureeing that in there
Wow these little trick so that may give
it the right amount of protein to make
it a complete meal but the dessert is
also it's a chocolate chocolate chip
sheet cake and it's made in a sheet pan
actually I don't even use a bowl to make
it I just make the whole batter and
everything right and so it's just really
fun and moist and delicious it's made
with whole grain flour and oil and that
of butter and so it's it's good for it's
better for you too yeah better it's
better Mon it's dessert well talk about
your evolution because you said you were
B were born loving food I was but you
really had a tough time with your weight
yeah you know what I really took me a
lot of time
in my life to find a place where I was
nourishing myself well I started off
really eating all the time when I was a
kid and being over weighted and having
them not a good self-image in that
regard and I was really in active also I
just didn't feel good about myself what
brought you there what you can we taught
you there to that point I don't know a
lot of different factors like there's so
many things but also you know I always
joke you know food is love in my family
and I think I was very well loved put it
that way
but but really it was just also my own
self-image of not being active you know
not getting out there but anyway what
then in my teens I actually really
started restricting too much and I
became overly thin overly almost
obsessed with food and it's so wonderful
in studying nutrition and my own
evolution of coming to this place where
I know how to nourish myself I still
love food and it is my joy in life to
bring this love of food to people but in
a healthy way and that's really my
mission because you can be there and
that's what these recipes really are
meaning to bring literally to the table
in every possible way you know you
started out as a pre-med student then
you went into nutrition and in terms of
how you got from that place and then
looking at meals that are still healthy
and delicious at the same time coming
from someone you said that sort of
struggled with food how did you make
that transition yeah well I was pre-med
in college I love science I love health
science and I was pre-med because I
loved food I was pre-med but I majored
in nutrition because I loved food and it
fulfilled all those med requirements as
I was studying nutrition I realized the
depth and breadth of the field and how
much there how much my passion was
really for that when you're 18 and
you're going into college you don't
realize how much there is to it and so
so I'm so happy that I wound up studying
that it helped me individually and it
helped me in terms of like really
fostering a wonderful food career that I
just love and and bringing this food to
people so so these brownies are healthy
yes definitely better for you dessert
and it's so moist and delicious too and
I think that's one of the things that
often gets lost in the conversation
about healthy eating right people don't
talk about taste yes
like why aren't we sumptuously enjoying
every bite that we put in our mouth we
absolutely should be and we are and I
have to say as you sign this ish yes if
you could share this meal with anyone
past or present who would it be okay so
it would have to be my grandmother who
I'm named after I never got to meet so I
would love to share a meal with her and
and from what I understand she was a
wonderful cook so maybe she would have
even cooked it great which as chef
rather Ellie Krieger we thank you for
joining us ever more on Ellie and the
dish head to our website at CBS this
morning dot-com